Yes, what are your thoughts on the low carb keto diet to reduce carbs and sugars since cancer is a bit about disease and its energy is driven by sugars and carbs.
I'm on an under 50, I think 50 gram carb diet.
Oh, and eating plenty of protein organic free range and plant based things. Yes, we write about that a lot.
You know, most cancers are going to find a fuel source. The easiest fuel source is glucose. So, and then they find the glucose they feed very cancer cells tend to feed very inefficiently.
That through the endpoint of your callysis not through the Krebs cycle, so they feed through lactate, which is an anaerobic function of fuel source, which is inefficient.
But it partly has to do with issues with the HIV HIF1 gene partly has to do with cancer cells rapid replication isn't producing.
A lot of the enzyme to convert proveic acid into acetyl quenzyme A necessary to go into the Krebs cycle, so it converts it to lactic acid and it needs off the lactic acid.
So yes, going on a low carb diet, a keto like diet and measuring your glucose.
You don't have to necessarily get into full ketosis, but measure your glucose levels and try to get your glucose down into the 70s.
Information has come out about how you have just as good a success with a cancer patient with that to try to get into full ketosis.
It's very difficult to be in full ketosis and to stay in full ketosis.
It's not all together necessary. So if you can be on a keto like diet where you're getting your glucose levels down as low as possible, you could have just as good a success.
So measuring your carbs per gram can be really good, but everybody's a little bit different.
So I mean, you could be eating only 40 grams of carbs a day and your glucose is still at 98 fasting blood glucose till 98.
And this is where going on a type of certificate or some sort of modified faster diet to help reset that metabolism can be beneficial.
So measuring your blood glucose, I think is gives you a more accurate picture of where your gram per day carbs should be at.
So you also don't want to go into a hypoglycemic state where your blood glucose is down below, you know, 50 or something like that and you're getting the shakes and all that kind of stuff.
So measuring your blood glucose I think is a good way to go.